In this section, we will wrap up the custom body workflow by going over step 5, where
we validate the results, check for seam issues, and generate the final DNA and export the
head LODs as FBX.
So let's jump back into Maya and execute step 5.
Back inside of Maya, now that this process is complete and with the new skin weights
written to the DNA file, we can now check the results with step 5.
Select line 202 to 211 and execute it.
This will load the new DNA and constrain the head core joint hierarchy to the body so that
we can check the results to see if the skin weight merge was successful.
Now that this is finished loading, in the viewport, I will switch to the top view to
bring this closer.
Then in the Outliner, I will collapse the head group and then collapse the head geometry
and hide all of the other LODs.
And then I will hide the spine.
I will switch over to Rotate mode and then I will select the body rig root and make the
joints visible.
I will select the arm joint and I will rotate the arm to check and see if there are any
seam issues in the front.
And then turn the body around and check the back area.
We can see that the skin weight merge was successful and that there are no gaps at the
seam lines between the head mesh and body.
If you notice a line along the seam area, this indicates a difference in normals.
Matching the normals would be the last step of this workflow.
For this character, the normals have already been matched.
Now before we move on to the final step, let's do a quick review of step 5.
Step 5 validates the results by constraining the head core joint hierarchies to the body
to test.
Select all of step 5 from line 202 to 211 and execute it.
This will connect the skeletal hierarchies and we can check the skin weights by moving
the joints located along the neck seam line.
We can select the clavicles and rotate them to ensure that no gaps appear at the seam
between the body and head mesh.
For this character, the normals have already been matched.
However, if you are using your own metahuman character, you will need to match the normals
at this point.
If everything looks good, the next step is to export the final DNA head LODs as FBX.
So let's return to Maya and complete this workflow.
Back inside of Maya, we can now run the export to FBX portion of this script.
Select this entire section from line 218 to 225 and execute it.
This process will extract joint information from the body rig to extend the joints that
are described in the DNA file.
This will add the root joint, the spine, the neck, and the shoulder joints.
And then it will export 1 FBX per LOD and assign shaders.
As we wait for this process to complete, let's do a quick review of the export FBX
step.
The export FBX portion of this script will extend the joint information from the body
rig to the DNA derived joints.
This will grab the joint information from the body rig and extend it to the DNA derived
joints and add the root, spine, neck, and shoulder joints.
They will then export 1 FBX per LOD and assign shaders to each of the head geometry assets.
The images on this slide demonstrate what the final head LOD FBX will look like for
LOD 0.
We can see how the skeleton has been updated from our atomic savage DNA to the final DNA.
Now that the custom body workflow is complete, let's return to Maya one last time to locate
the assets we will need to bring into Unreal Engine and finalize the rig.
Back in Maya, all of the LODs have been exported.
In the export folder, we have the final DNA file and all of the head LOD FBX files and
the body skeletal mesh with the modified skin weights.
Inside of the viewport, we can see that the skeleton has been updated.
And if we go to the Outliner and select the head mesh, if I go to the right over here
and open up the Attributes Editor, we will see that a shader has been applied to the
head and labeled correctly.
And this is also the case for all of the other head geometry assets.
We are now ready to bring all of these assets into Unreal Engine and finalize our character.
Now let's wrap up this section by reviewing the assets that we will be bringing into Unreal
Engine.
The assets located in the export folder that will be brought into Unreal Engine include the
final metahuman DNA file, the exported head LODs as FBX, and the separated body mesh and
skeleton with the updated skin weights.
The body and head FBX will be Y up in Maya, which is fine.
Now that we have everything we need in order to finalize our customizations, in the next
section we will delve into our hands-on exercise and go through the steps of bringing these
assets into Unreal Engine.